[Music]
pass it out edwards for three
and minnesota hot shooting early
[Applause]
edwards
that's good
wow and you know what's great about that
play is marcus howard has been making
his threes at a pretty consistent clip
lately and so the timberwolves actually
went to double team him almost that gave
jokic the open look nuggets nation has
deemed it yolk yolk miss like christmas
[Applause]
number 15.
element that michael malone talked about
in the pregame presser
live ball turnovers
anthony edwards takes a contested three
knocks it in
wow
edwards
wants to square up
he draws jeff green now
he does and he knocks it in
[Music]
now beasley trying to get along the
baseline
corner three and another three-pointer
made by anthony edwards
been a good performance
by minnesota
now
edwards over the top and he hits another
built their confidence they got going
and
to be honest it was a little bit of a
case of
not knowing personnel as well as you
should because oh my god it's that step
back right there into a lot of
three-pointers anthony evans has had a
heck of a night shooting a three-point
shot and
120-101
[Applause]
edwards still in still firing and he
knocks in another one